[Music]
between me and my sister there's a lot
of competition it's a race everybody
wants to win but off-track or just like
any other normal teenager we hang out
with our family with our friends but in
racing it's where we feel most alive my
name is Amna cabeza I'm 17 years old
and my name is Hamed Elko Basie and I'm
15 years old and we are the first MRT
female drivers what I love most about
racing is you can always do better and
better it's the best feeling when you
feel the speed and you can improve so
fast just by focusing
I first became interested in girl
carding when I saw my dad racing inside
and outside of the UAE all he ever
talked about was racing and meeting
different drivers around the world and
going to different trucks he's always
there to help me calm down and he plays
a really big role in my racing career
I have been racing professionally since
2009 I first noticed the talent in my
daughter
Aminah when she was 3 years old she's so
acquired and she wanted to drive it and
before even giving her any instructions
she knew where the throttle is where the
brakes are by me did he know that she
had the touch handle her sister she
wanted to also to get into racing and
she surprised us all because in their
first season she was able to win races
[Music]
so far I have 16 trophies and 3 wins
I've won over 20 trophies including 4
wins and still counting
my mom she helps me she takes me to the
tracks she takes me around the world
yeah she's she's the best both of them
are always competing which make it very
interesting for us as a family it's very
interesting to see them racing against
voice it show how girls can race against
a boy and can win a race
being the first Emirati to win the UAE
RMC championship is pretty big
there is no female variety that's done
it before it was a big achievement
I believe my daughters are breaking
barriers for women in general and Arab
women in particular we're happy to see
that people's perception are being
changing about our region and culture
and about women in general and I believe
that this is great for motorsports
[Music]